then I get yourself into a hazmat suit  agent we just got word that the  experimental antivirals lost in the dark  zone have been located there's no time  to wait you in a team need to go secure  them right now or someone else will come  on move it we don't have a time we need  to be in the air before the storm hit  but we've got a storm coming in they say  it'll make sandy look like a snowball  fight by locking the base down for the  duration and Rhodes says the weather  might work all our comms so we can't  count on being in contact  just get there before the storm really  hits and listen do whatever you need to  do to get back alive you need it now out